ce chorégraphe qu'on ne présente plus
nous parle de son tout nouveau spectacle
inspiré des mille et une nuits et du
personnage de sherazade une manière de
parler de la femme dans nos sociétés et
d'un orient magique vous pourrez
apprécier notamment du 31 mai au 2 juin
au théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
voici angelin prejlocaj dans le kiosque
j'avais besoin de renouer avec la
méditerranée surtout dans le cadre de
marseille provence 2013 dont le thème
était justement la méditerranée puisque
marseille fait face à cet univers de
lorient et du rêve aussi et donc les
mille et une nuits me paraissait un bond
theme pour répondre à cet appel de
marseille provence 2013 et donc je me
suis penché sur ce sur ce monument de
de la littérature mondiale et magie et
découvert des tas de choses que je ne
savais pas
mais
m
dans cette oeuvre il ya beaucoup de
sensualité il ya beaucoup d'érotisme
il ya de la violence aussi
tout n'est pas tout rose parce qu'on
connaît bien sûr toutes les les condamna
d'un et la lampe merveilleuse ali baba
et les 40 voleurs mais en fait il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont beaucoup
plus ambigu complexe
violence je vais 10 et rôti et puis
surtout il ya la figure de shéhérazade
qui est pour moi la tire et c'est une
des premières féministes de lorient fait
puisque avec sa sagesse sa culture son
intelligence son savoir elle
et son imagination elle fait un rempart
à la barbarie de ce type qui est un roi
qui est trompé par sa femme il l'a tué
ensuite ils décident chaque soir chaque
jour d'épouser une nouvelle femme et
lendemain de l'actuelle pour éviter
qu'elle ne le trompe évidemment
sur le plateau c'est pas aussi illustré
parce que je voulais absolument pas
tourné dans l'illustration
c'est plutôt une évocation presque
impressionniste de mes sensations à la
lecture des mille et une nuits con qu'on
va voir
alors donc il ya effectivement de la
coupe il ya de la violence et de
l'érotisme et de la sensualité
j'espère et voilà et du mystère
j'ai essayé de retrouver à l'aune de la
calligraphie suggestions qu'ils puissent
s'accorder à ça qu'ils puissent trouver
un écho à cette magnifique
calligraphique se déploie à la fois dans
l'écriture orientale et est aussi dans
l'abstraction qu'on trouve par exemple
sur les tapis d'orient
il ya quelque chose qui est une sorte de
le labyrinthe abyssal quand on regarde
un tapis on pourrait presque être
absorbé par par les figures qui sont là
et qui vont ils prennent un peu comme
comme certains dessins de est cher par
exemple mais évidemment orientaliste en
fait
moi j'essaye toujours de faire des
trouver à la fois la gestuelle les
collaborateurs qui sont les plus à même
de
d'évoquer afin de nourrir la thématique
quand je suis sur une thématique comme
celle-là de lorient évidemment je me
suis beaucoup inspiré de lorient d'un
musée dit la calligraphie et tout ça est
aimée collaboration énormément nourrit
aussi donc
natacha atlas constance guisset qui a
fait les décors azzedine alaïa natacha
atlas oui c'est une musicienne chanteuse
que j'admirais beaucoup que j'admire
toujours qu'il était pour moi vraiment
le symbole de la fusion des cultures
musicales avec son orientalisme enfin
avec ses origines et puis aussi connecté
vraiment à la musique plus plus techno
par exemple
electro et et c'est aussi un alliage
dire qu'on est dans la demande et dans
la dans la transmission dans l'échangé
des cultures musicales et c'est ça que
j'aime beaucoup avec elle
azzedine alaïa c'est pour moi c'est
l'homme qui vient de lorient et qui a su
donner à la fois une liberté un rêve une
une audace à la femme aux femmes en
général une femme habillée en alaïa et
toujours à la fois guerrière à la fois
souveraine à la fois sensuel à la fois
émouvante et donc j'avais très envie de
travailler avec lui
il
sujet la rédaction
mais qui le suivent
michel une femme une voix un projet
artistique et bientôt sur la scène du
scarabée à la verrière artistes
yvelinoise en compétition le vendredi 17
mai pour les envols du scarabée michel
se prépare avec audrey son coach vocal
et scénique m'apporte énormément au
niveau vocal puisque avec lg ça fait un
an et demi maintenant que je suis c'est
cours donc je pensais pas mal progressé
face à elle mais là ce que j'attends
d'elle c'est plus effectivement un
coaching scénique pour avoir une vraie
cohésion au niveau du groupe pour que
moi je puisse être plus au delà du champ
dans l'interprétation en fait de chacun
du texte parce que les textes que
j'écris sont assez fort et je voudrais
vraiment que la mise en scène soit
service en fait et des chansons à quel
moment tu passes du côté du rocher pour
audrey le coach est le miroir de
l'artiste sont drôles et de
l'accompagner pour optimiser l'harmonie
entre ses textes
la mise en scène et son interprétation
l'artiste arrive avec son projet là par
exemple elle va commencer à faire les
morceaux par exemple si on travaille sur
toute seule elle fait le morceau qu'elle
a choisi donc je la laisse faire et je
vais regarder un peu cette comment elle
va tourner je vais commencer à poser des
questions à voir pourquoi telle chose
pourquoi elle a procédé comme ça mais tu
y es tu toi dedans
candidats jouent ce nouveau tremplin de
la chanson française et surtout pour
michel une occasion de rencontres avec
le public
à
j'ai commencé à écrire des poèmes et
puis après c'était des chansons et puis
bon j'avais toi renvoie à peu près
intéressant donc qui me permettait
effectivement d'interpréter mais mes
propres compositions
et puis j'ai rencontré donc audrey qui
m'a permis de monter sur scène pour la
première fois et ça a été une expérience
que je n'oublierai pas banque était très
forte pour moi l'expression un peu
décollé et puis et des transfusions avec
les gens en face donc c'est voilà
j'espère qu'à ça maintenant ma
particularité c'est de proposer la
chanson française avec plein de couleurs
donc ça passe du swing au reggae ont
fait du blues ont fait la valse créole
on fait du rock
voilà donc la plein plein de couleurs
différentes
michel écrit et compose ses chansons des
textes empreints d'émotion qui oscille
entre fragilité et puissance à l'époque
son histoire est peut être un peu la
nôtre
en prison
en
où
on vient
mais encore quelques dates à retenir
avant votre partie de jeu de rôle
grandeur nature le chorégraphe sylvain
groud et les musiciens du cabaret
contemporain vous feront découvrir music
for eighteen musicians le 24 mai au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
tandis qu'elsa grana vous présentera les
enfants d'edward bond
les 23 et 24 mai à la ferme de bel ébat
à guyancourt toujours le 24 mai dick
annegarn sera en concert au scarabée à
la verrière et le 25
vous pourrez découvrir le sacre de roger
bernat ou prises et l'encours des dates
que vous pouvez retrouver ainsi que
l'ensemble de la programmation des
salles saint-quentinoise sur internet
aux adresses qui s'affiche et n'oubliez
pas que tous les mardis sur le
www.cusm.ca qui point fr vous pouvez
gagner des places de spectacle alors
jouer gagner amusez-vous à bientôt le
chemin